Eighteen years ago, when Wayde was about thirty years of age, he was a failure.
This was surprising because he was a clever man, and most people liked him.
Wayde's best friend was a doctor, an older man named Manningtree.
One day, Manningtree said to Wayde, "I have known you for many years, Wayde...
...and I am surprised you are such a failure."
"Your problem, Wayde," Manningtree said,...
..."is that you have no confidence in yourself."
"And I'm sure that if you were more confident,...
...you could be very successful in everything."
"Oh, I don't think so," Wayde said.
"Every time I try to do something, I am sure I shall fail."
"The reason you think that," Manningtree said,...
..."is that you suffer from nerves."
"You're right," Wayde said.
"I do worry and I am nervous about everything."
"But what can I do about it?"
"There is a medicine that cures nerves," Manningtree said.
"Just take one small drop of the medicine once a month," Manningtree said.
Wayde took the bottle from his friend.
Once a month, he took one small drop.
The effect was immediate.
Suddenly, he was not nervous anymore.